The Promise object is used for
deferred and asynchronous computations.
Okay, great.
This statement is less than helpful
if you're understanding of the word
asynchronous is less than certain.
So, the question is,
what is asynchronous work?
Asynchronous work happens at
an unknown or unpredictable time.
Normally code is synchronise.
One statement executes, like this one,
and there's a guarantee that
the next statement executes
immediately afterwards.
Threading on processors doesn't
necessarily guarantee that, however,
the JavaScript threading model
ensures that for all intents and
purposes, JavaScript runs
in a single timeline.
Unlike synchronise code.
Asynchronous code is not guaranteed to
execute in a single unbroken timeline.
In fact,
you should assume that you have no idea
when asynchronous
operations will complete.
In a situation like this, for example,
you can't even assume that just because
you sent out the first request first and
the second request second,
that the first request will
return sooner than the second.
Assume that either order is equally
likely, as the fact that one or
both requests just
might fail altogether.
Network requests aren't the only
examples of asynchronous code.
Any code that relies on processes like
these, like events, like threads, or
just some kind of unknowable
finishing time are asynchronous.
So, the big question is, what is the
best way to handle asynchronous code?
Okay, the answer is obviously promises.
That's why you're here.